c'est un signe que le scrutin approche à
60 jours du vote
les affiches électorales pousse sur les
pelouse d'ottawa mais un autre indice ne
trompe pas les libéraux prennent les
grands moyens pour définir leur
principal adversaire en ressortant une
déclaration faite par andrew scheer à la
chambre des communes
il y a plus de dix ans chaque chien en
plein débat sur le mariage entre
personnes de même sexe indochine a
affirmé que pour survivre
la société doit mettre des enfants au
monde ce qui lui a fait dire que les
unions homosexuelles ont un caractère
opposé puisqu'il n'ya pas de
complémentarité des sexes
si les libéraux dépoussiérer cette
vieille vidéo les positions d'un duo
scheer sur le mariage entre personnes de
même sexe était connue le jour où il
s'est lancé dans la course pour
remplacer stephen harper andrew scheer a
indiqué qu'il n'a pas l'intention de
rouvrir ce débat
le défendons les droits des lgbt nous
défendons le mariage tel qu'il est
prescrit par la loi de notre parti aux
ténois sur l'étude ne tient pas toujours
été clair là dessus mais que les
libéraux sur des vieilles qu'il ya 15
ans ça démontre sont complètement
désespérée de pour détourner l'attention
des pires scandales de corruption de
l'histoire des tic de snc lavalin
mais les libéraux n'en démordent pas et
mettent en bouche au défi de participer
à un défilé de la fierté gaie
un débat est clos mais monsieur chine
refuse quand même de participer à des
marches des fiertés partout au pays
son absence a été remarquée ça fait
encore une fois ce n'est pas un dossier
clos parce que personne ne vais pas
s'exprimer puis supporter la communauté
et génétiques liées pour le chef néo
démocrate
les questions sur les valeurs
d'indochine mérite d'être posée est ce
qu'ils partagent ses valeurs encore il
faut les dénoncer et fodic et ce n'est
pas acceptable mais ça me soulèvent de
grandes inquiétudes qui il a des valeurs
comme ça la campagne électorale n'est
pas encore déclenché que le ton des
attaques et déjà donné si les libéraux
tentent de définir leurs adversaires
indochine n'a pas l'intention de se
faire dicter la marche à suivre
il ne participera pas au prochain défilé
de la fierté gaie à ottawa il si
madeleine blé morin radio canada ottawa